inflation has Americans worried really
worried 83 of Americans surveyed said it
was a source of stress meanwhile the
luxury Market is booming at lvmh which
includes Brands like Louis Vuitton Dior
Fendi Tiffany and Tag Heuer revenues are
up 23 last year so what gives it's
called Revenge inflation spending when
middle class consumers alternate between
penny pinching and splurging like when
you pack your lunch to keep costs down
but then you impossibly buy a luxury bag
here's what's going on in our brains
when we're making financial decisions
that seem to conflict
to order or not to order little
financial decisions like this have more
of an impact on our financial future and
present because of inflation this chart
tracks the changes in prices for
everything from electricity to food and
clothes and as you can see and have
probably already felt things are
expensive the prospect of layoffs is
also causing additional stress
increasing incentives to cut costs
wherever we can but self-control can be
hard it creates a conflict between a
long-term goal of saving and our need to
feel good now that conflict plays out in
areas of the brain involved in cognitive
control and processing rewards say
you're thinking of getting a fancy latte
the brain's reward circuit which
includes the amygdala and the ventral
striatum motivates you to treat yo sell
but then there's a prefrontal cortex
which handles impulse control and helps
you plan for the future Candace Rayo a
cognitive neuroscientist who studies
self-control says that the brain
integrates signals from these areas to
come up with a reward value that value
is determined by how beneficial a
certain Choice might be and that's
what's driving Choice behavior when you
skip that latte your prefrontal cortex
nudges that reward value toward more
financially sound decisions so it helps
us choose in favor of our long-term
goals this Balancing Act is relevant to
any choice where there's an inherent
conflict between short and long-term
outcomes researchers used to think that
when we gave into Temptations the
ability of our prefrontal cortex to
exert self-control was just poof gone
instead it's limited kind of like your
money so if you've been constantly
making tiny decisions about how to save
on groceries or how to cut down on your
electric bill you may not have enough
cognitive resources to keep yourself
from splurging that's what happened to
my co-worker Rachel wolf she wrote an
article about revenge spending after
dropping 40 dollars on hand soap so not
everybody is splurging it obviously
requires a little bit of flexibility in
your budget what drove me was definitely
frustration and I've been trading down
in so many other places in my life
Rachel and the other consumers she spoke
to figured the iffy economy wasn't going
to change anytime soon and when they
chose to splurge it was because
self-control simply cost them too much I
think it speaks to the mental gymnastics
we're all doing and
um it's it's The Balancing Act there's
two things going on here first our
brains value rewards in the future less
than rewards in the present and second
stress this includes Financial stress
which may magnify or desire to feel good
it also compromises the ability of the
prefrontal cortex to control impulsive
behavior stress-related hormones like
norepinephrine and cortisol can impair
the ability of the prefrontal cortex to
incentivize behavior that aligns with
their long-term goals stress also makes
reward areas more sensitive to dopamine
a molecule that makes us feel good this
is why stress can make rewards seem more
rewarding and self-control more
difficult so you kind of have a a double
hit in pairing these self control
decisions that means that stressors like
inflation Rising housing costs and
plagues can prime us for indulgent
behavior and this is a problem right
because it's when we're under stress
that we really need these resources to
control our behavior and make choices
that align with our long-term goals so
what can you do to make sure you're nice
to yourself without breaking the bank to
get answers I called up my goaliers a
cognitive psychologist at Wells Fargo
don't be overly Frugal unnecessarily
because that can exhaust your mind
Michael also suggested writing a list of
small traits that make you happy but
won't set you back financially he and
Candace told me that exerting
self-control all the time isn't
necessarily good either in reframing
financial discipline is rewarding can
also help especially if you actually get
to see the money piling up in the
banking which also leads to a peace of
mind emotion that a lot of people say
the desire when it comes to their money
he suggested keeping a financial diary
and updating it at 3 6 and 12 months to
track your progress hopefully seeing
those dollars adding up will give you
the burst of dopamine you need to
motivate you to keep saving and avoid
too much Revenge spending just keep in
mind that dopamine isn't just the
feel-good molecule it's also about
motivation